우리 VQE 알고리즘의 성공은
우리가 선택하는 상태와 circuit에
크게 달려 있어요.
저는 Victoria Lipinska이고, 이 영상에서는
그 선택지들을 살펴볼 거예요.
어떤 옵션들이 있는지 알아봐요.
VQE의 양자 파트를 실행할 때마다
등장하는
모든 요소들을 자세히
살펴볼게요.
먼저 레퍼런스 상태, 즉
초기 상태라고도 부르는 것부터 시작해요.
레퍼런스 상태를 파라미터화된
circuit에 통과시키는데, 이걸
variational form이라고 해요.
처음엔 파라미터 초기값을 사용하고,
그 다음 circuit을 통과한 상태를
Hamiltonian 기저에서 측정해서
기댓값을 구해요. 이제
각 요소를 하나씩 살펴볼게요.
레퍼런스 상태부터 시작해요.
레퍼런스 상태의 일반적인 선택은
영(zero) 상태예요.
그게 바로 양자 컴퓨터가
이미 초기화된 상태거든요.
양자 화학 문제의 경우에는,
소위 Hartree-Fock 상태를
사용할 수도 있어요.
이건 Hartree-Fock 방법의
결과물이에요.
간단히 말하면, Hartree-Fock 이론은
레퍼런스 상태를 구성하는
간단한 방법을 제공해요. 양자 시스템의
바닥 상태를 근사하는 방식으로요.
상태 공간 내에서의 회전을 찾아서
바닥 상태 에너지를 최소화해요.
마지막으로, 레퍼런스 상태는
문제에 따라 매우 특수할 수 있어서,
커스텀 상태를 선택하고
싶을 수도 있어요.
시스템의 특성을 알고 있을 때, 예를 들어
대칭성이나
상태 내 전자의 특정 개수를 알면,
그걸 활용해서
VQE 알고리즘의 수렴을
더 잘 이끌 수 있어요.
좋은 레퍼런스 상태를 고르는 건
수렴에 중요해요.
바닥 상태에 가까운
레퍼런스 상태는
문제를 훨씬 더 쉽고 빠르게
수렴시킬 수 있어요.
마찬가지로 중요한 건
variational form에 넣어주는
초기 파라미터 값의 선택이에요.
따라서 레퍼런스 상태와
초기 파라미터에 따라,
빠르게 수렴할 수도, 느리게 수렴할 수도,
아니면 아예 수렴하지 않을 수도 있어요.
이 그래프를 보면서, 시각화를 위해
파라미터 공간에 파라미터가
딱 하나만 있다고 상상해봐요.
아주 좋은 레퍼런스 상태를 사용하면
최종 바닥 상태에 매우 가까운 곳에서
시작할 수 있어서
수렴이 빠르게 돼요.
반대로, 바닥 상태에서 아주 멀리,
예를 들어 여기에서 시작하면,
레퍼런스 상태 a처럼,
높은 에너지 장벽을 넘어야 해서
수렴이 매우 느려지거나
아예 안 될 수 있어요.
이 부분은 이 코스의
고전적 최적화 모듈에서
더 깊이 다룰 거예요.
이제 레퍼런스 상태에 작용하는
파라미터 circuit을, 즉
variational form을 살펴볼게요.
이 circuit, 즉 theta에 대한 U가
레퍼런스에 작용하면
시험 상태라고 부르는 걸
만들어내요.
theta의 psi, 또는 ansatz라고도 해요.
이 ansatz 상태가 적절한 기저에서
측정되어
에너지에 대한 기댓값을
얻게 돼요.
여기서 다루는
variational form들은